[Applaudissements]
W
papa quel malheur quel grand malheur
pour moi
W
papa quel scandale si maman savait ça à
trinidat tout là-bas aux Antilles à
trinidat vivait une famille il y avait
la MAM le papa et le Grandfils est né il
y a 40 ans n'était toujours pas marié un
jour il trouva la fille qu'il voulait il
dit à son père je voudrais l'épouser
etlas mon garçon hélas tu ne peux pas
car cette fille est ta sœur et ta mère
ne le sait pas
W
papa quel malheur quel grand malheur
pour moi
W
papa quel scandale si maman savait ça le
temps passa puis le garçon un soir
trouvé son père et lui dit plein
d'espoir la maîtresse d'école veut bien
m'épouser mais le pauvre père prit un
air accablé mon fils tu ne peux pas tu
ne peux pas faire ça car cette fille est
ta sœur ta mère ne le sait
[Musique]
pas quel malheur quel grand malheur pour
moi
W
papa quel scandale si maman savait ça
ans après il revint tout ému et dit à
son père devine ce que j'ai vu dans la
plantation on vient d'embaucher plus de
50 filles du village d' côté
has mon pauvre enfant les dieux sont
contre toi car ces pus son tes surs ta
mère ne sait
pas
papa quel malheur quel grand malheur
pour
moi
papa Scand si maman savait
ça patience il s'en fut écuré raconter à
sa mère toute la vérité
la mère se mit à rire et lui dit t'en
fais pas ton père n'est pas ton père ton
père ne sait pas
W
maman quel bonheur quel grand bonheur
pour moi W
MAM quel scandale si papa savait ça
[Musique]
W
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]